what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and after an unexpected
one week hiatus blacklord is back with
the final battle against the dark triad
the dark triad have been the main
villains for a very long time but now
that is changing quickly as new and even
more powerful threats emerge so let's
get into it if you enjoyed the black
clover videos on this channel and you
want us to make more you know what to do
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it really helps
with the youtube algorithm and if you're
new to the channel or maybe you watch
our videos but you just haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a favor
and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror finally this video will of
course contain black clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned now as i mentioned
in my last black clover video the
previous chapter of the manga was easily
one of the most controversial chapters
in the entire series a lot of fans had
mixed feelings about certain aspects of
the chapter especially mimosas ability
to instantly revive three characters
from the brink of death the reactions
ranged from people who were totally
outraged to people like me who weren't
fans of it but are still enjoying the
story two people who think that black
clover can do no wrong and that anyone
who finds any fault in it is a terrible
terrible person so basically it was just
a perfectly normal week for anime and
manga fandom to be fair i think that
most of us always expected that rill and
charlotte would be okay but gaia in
particular was a step too far for a lot
of people i mean he had used up all of
his life force while fighting megicula
his body had begun to crumble and even
he himself had accepted that he was
going to die so when he was healed in a
matter of seconds as soon as mimosa
arrived it didn't really fit with the
story's own narrative about gaia's
condition up until that point i know
from the comment section on that video
that people are still debating the
chapter as we speak but thankfully we
can now move beyond this controversy
because the latest chapter switches
gears and takes us to the final battle
against the dark triad the showdown
between yuno and langus on the one side
and xenon and his devil on the other the
battle comes down to this juno needs
language to buy him three minutes that
is how much time juno requires to
prepare a new attack an attack that juno
believes is going to end the fight and
take xenon out in order to carry out
this attack yuno needs that time to
build up his magic power but he can't do
it if he has to keep dealing with
xenon's attacks and that is where
langris comes in langris has to act as a
decoy who will keep xenon busy long
enough for yuno to make his move that
sounds simple enough in theory but in
practice languas is no match for xenon
when it comes to raw power language may
be able to dodge xenon's attacks and
contribute to the battle a bit with
euno's help but the prospect of langris
holding off xenon on his own for three
whole minutes seems like an utterly
impossible task and yet langris knows
that he has no
other choice if he can't be the one to
take xenon out then he has to do his
very best to give yuno an opportunity to
deliver that finishing blow langris
knows that the life of the golden dawn
captain is at stake the sacrifice and
legacy of all of those killed golden
dawn members is also at stake and the
pressure is on juno senses that langris
needs a bit of a pep talk so he reminds
langris that he is the strongest spatial
mage in the clover kingdom and so he
can't let himself lose not even to
someone like xenon now most mages can't
even use their magic inside xenon's
spatial mana domination zone as you will
recall xenon is able to take control of
all the mana within a certain
cube-shaped area and the majority of
mages are helpless against xenon once
they are trapped within his spatial mana
domination zone thankfully there are a
few exceptions one exception are mages
who are loved by mana such as yuno yuno
is able to resist xenon's mana control
and continue fighting even inside his
spatial mana domination zone the second
exception are other spatial magic users
and particularly spatial mages who have
achieved the ability to use mana zone
and so language uses his own spatial
magic monozone to negate the effects of
xenon's spatial domination zone langris
essentially creates his own smaller
spatial magic space within xenon's
larger spatial magic space if that makes
any sense because now that i've said it
i feel like it makes no sense but the
point is as long as language stays
within his own smaller space he can
still use his magic and defend against
xenon's attacks as yuno praises langris
for finding a way to fight back against
xenon langris thinks back to the time
when juno first joined the golden dawn
squad back then langris thought that
yuno was just a cocky and arrogant kid
and he couldn't bear the thought of one
day being surpassed by someone like yuno
however langris now realizes that he
disliked yuno because he reminded him so
much of himself the two of them are
actually very similar and so langris saw
yuno as a rival and as a potential
threat in terms of his own goals and
ambitions meanwhile xenon isn't too
interested in this burgeoning bromance
he is confident that neither language
nor yuno have the kind of magic that
could defeat him and he thinks that his
ultimate victory is just moments away
and i mean xenon has a point langris is
already struggling to keep up his
resistance and he tells yuno to please
hurry up on the bright side langris has
finally realized that juno's confident
attitude was never a threat to the
golden dawn it was never self-indulgent
or harmful to the squad in fact you know
strength confidence and competitiveness
inspired the rest of the squad and drove
them to become stronger langris finally
comes to fully accept yuno as his
teammate and as someone who is driving
the squad forward language then summons
up the courage to tell yuno that he
accepts him as the vice captain of the
golden dawn and while this emotional and
meaningful bro moment is happening
between langris and yuno xenon is
basically like guys guys please i don't
give a damn about your squad or your
bromance i'm way stronger than you are
and in the end power will prevail so
stop wasting my time with this lame
bonding stuff your persistence is futile
and to be honest it's also kind of
cringe i am paraphrasing but that's
pretty much what xenon is thinking and
yet even against these overwhelming odds
and even against a far stronger opponent
langris refuses to give in he lunges at
xenon declaring that he and his comrades
will never stop persisting because they
are the strongest magic knight squad the
golden dawn at this point langris
appears to sustain some serious damage
from xenon's bone magic tentacle things
but his superhuman determination manages
to occupy xenon long enough for uno to
finally make his move with a smirk on
his face yuno reveals a new wind spirit
creation magic spell called the spirit
of urus which allows yuno to manifest a
massive and majestic bow and arrow as
you know aims the arrow at a clearly
worried xenon this intense and
action-packed chapter comes to an end
whoa throughout this entire chapter
xenon's facial expression barely changed
and he didn't seem worried for even a
second but as soon as he saw yuno's new
spell xenon's expression instantly
turned very grave and very worried so
from that alone it is clear that juno's
new spell is incredibly powerful judging
by xenon's expression he must feel that
juno's new spell has the potential to
seriously injure him or maybe even kill
him altogether so it looks like yuno
might have been right he may really be
able to end this battle with one single
attack
but will it really be that easy will you
know really just go all robin hood on
xenon and xenon's just gonna drop dead
from one arrow or is defeating xenon
going to prove to be a bit harder than
that oh and even if xenon is defeated
sometime soon where does the story go
from there as you guys know i've been
saying for a while that the dark triad
are not the true main villains of this
arc and that the real threat are most
likely morris and the highest ranked
devils who emerge from the cliffhoth but
even so the dark triad have been the
primary villains of the story for a long
time so if all three of them are about
to be defeated what happens next
definitely let me know what you guys
think is going to happen next if all
three members of the dark triad are
defeated down in the comments below also
what did you think of language in this
chapter and do you think that he
sustained serious injuries while holding
off xenon he definitely seemed to be
injured there was blood there but this
is black clover and they do have shenron
mimosa now so he'll probably be fine
finally what did you think of yuno's new
robin hood spell and is it really as
strong as it looks let me know down
below if you enjoyed this black clover
video and you want to see more in the
future just leave a like to let me know
it really helps a lot and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting the option that says all if
you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
quick thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to alpha
sigma he is an absolute mad lad and
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algertol hinokamien water the toasted
chi the spike dylan isidore spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist and
monkey d quilly finally thank you to all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the
red-haired raven on hell cruise ratheen
de ora very gucci alicia octor bonnie
parks joanne garcia ted no ted fatboy
games corey mcgowan and soul ray slice
and dice if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you